(music plays)
- Hey.
- Hi.
You're Izzie right?
I'm Casey.
I'm the--
Sorry, you know that.
I'm like super nervous.
I'm the new kid from Newton.
- Look, new kid from Newton--
- Casey is my name actually.
- I'm sure you were hot shit
at your last crappy school but over here--
- Wow, warm welcome.
They should put you in
the orientation video.
- What'd you do for (mumbles)?
- Um, nothing really.
Went to Target a couple times.
(all laugh)
Um, I think I'm stretched.
Is this the path here?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- (laughs) She's hilarious.
- Newton?
- Yeah?
- This might sound lame but
you're like my new favorite person.
- Really?
(claps)
- (laughs) Yeah.
(both laugh)
(knocking)
- It's Pennywise.
- No.
I forgot I texted Nate.
- Nooo.
- Yeah, I know.
I'm sorry.
- He's gonna ruin the girl time.
- Let's just pretend that we're not here.
- We're not hooome.
- [Nate] Open the door you dummies.
(laughs)
- He's gonna make so much fun of us
for making this fort oh my God.
- Well boys ruin everything.
- Hey.
I was gonna tell you in
person but I chickened out.
So I wrote it obviously.
- You and Nate kissed?
- No, no, no.
He kissed me.
- That asshole.
- I know.
- I can't believe he did that.
I'm gonna kill him.
- Do you want to go talk about it?
- Nope.
Just need time to think.
Dude I'm sorry.
About everything.
I was a dick and I got jealous
and I was afraid of losing
someone that I love.
- I would never come between you and Nate.
- Screw him!
No I was afraid of losing you.
- So guess what?
I had sex again.
- With Evan?
- No with myself.
Still counts though right?
- (laughs) shut up.
- Yeah with Evan.
I really love him.
- I know you do.
- It's just sometimes a thing feels like--
so right, you know?
(music plays)
(music intensifies)
(phone vibrates)
- Everything okay?
- Yeah, he just had to get home.
- Hmm.
- Hey, I'm gonna sleep over
at Evan's next weekend.
Think you can cover for me?
- Um, yeah.
Yeah.
- Cool.
Look what I found at the thrift store!
- And I brought pie to make up for it.
- Sam I said no tweed.
- Oh my bad, I though you said only tweed.
- We'll make it work.
What time will Evan be arriving?
- He's working so Izzie's filling in.
- I'm her date.
- Oh, okay.
Tweed suit, new guest.
I mean what's in the pie, dog poop?
- The look on Page's face
was well worth the $11.
But I gotta say, this
suit itches like a bitch
and there's a spot on my back
that I can't quite reach.
- I can reach it.
- College just creates drones.
Cogs in the system, robots.
(Talks like robot) Must make money.
- (Talks like robot) Must each cheese.
(giggles)
- I am so sorry for how I
acted at the dinner party.
- Dude, it's okay.
- No, it's not okay.
I was just stirring shit up just because--
- What?
- Because I was jealous.
- Why?
- You know why.
You all right?
- Who wants eggs in the hole?
- Oh, I'm headed out.
- So early?
- Yeah I'm behind in Econ so I'm gonna
go to the student lounge and study.
- Should have told me nerd,
I would have come with you.
- Oh, hi.
- Hi.
- Hey.
- How was the bathroom?
- It was great, thank you for asking.
- We were just gonna--
- You know, make out a little.
(laughs nervously)
- Okay, yeah.
Okay, got it.
Okay, bye.
- Bye.
- Honestly, if I knew that you were
gonna be all weird and that this
was gonna jeopardize our friendship,
I never in a million years would have
told you how I felt.
Because it is becoming incredibly weird
that you don't feel the same way.
(romantic music plays)
(Inquisitive music plays)
- Look what sam made me.
- Who's Sphen and Magic?
- Gay penguins in Australia.
He told me about them last night.
- Wait did you tell Sam about us?
- Not really.
- Not really?
- Well I didn't tell him anything
he just saw us at the door.
What would be the big deal?
He's my brother.
- The big deal is I don't feel like
broadcasting my personal
business to the world.
- Okay, jeez.
- No it's not okay.
(dance music plays)
- What are you doing?
- Nothing, I'm dancing.
- We talked about this.
I don't need to advertise
my personal business
to the world.
- I'm not trying--
- I just, I need water.
I'm sorry.
- I'm sick of you apologizing.
You led me on, you're jerking me around.
I hate it.
(locker slams)
- I really like you.
- Yeah in this moment.
But in 10 minutes you
might be embarrassed by me
or kissing some random guy.
Just leave me alone.
- Newton!
- What?!
- I'm done being weird.
- That was pretty weird.
- Bad weird?